ist der weltraum ein supercomputer viele
filme geiseln inzwischen davon überzeugt
dass am ende alles auf informationen
basiert und jetzt schon scheint es so
dass quantencomputer nichts anderes sind
als es auf englisch ist mit dem wir
begonnen haben zu rechnen jetzt musiker
gibt aus kürbis also den biss eines
quantencomputers ableiten geht vom cube
heißt die initiative
was dahinter steckt und die bereits
gewonnenen absolut verblüffenden
erkenntnisse jetzt endlich zum science
fiction herzlich willkommen ja das darf
ist genau die gleichen buchstaben hat
wie it for information technology
informationstechnologie ist wohl kein
zufall immer mehr physiker sind davon
überzeugt dass alles unser gesamtes
weltall nichts als information ist quasi
ein riesiger supercomputer
demnach wären alle kosmischen vorgänger
mit einer programmiersprache geschrieben
und diesen code zu knacken die software
die programme oder das programm in der
dem allem zu finden das können sie die
große erkenntnis bedeuten das verstehen
der welt das wonach alle suchen und wir
hatten es ja in einem der letzten videos
professor hurun magazin spekuliert dass
die quantenverschränkung das gewebe der
raumzeit darstellt und damit die
verbindung zwischen relativitätstheorie
und quantenphysik an vertreter der
stringtheorie also der theorie die
besagt dass alles durch ein die
visionale fäden in elf dimensionen
geschrieben ist allerdings kommt wichtig
sie ist eine reine hypothese nicht
bewiesen einbringt theoretiker also
breit wie ein zug vom cupid wenn die
arbeit in dem bereich so erfolgreich
voran geht wie einige erwarten könnte
quanteninformation die nächste
revolution in unserem verständnis von
raum und zeit auslösen
das ist äußerst aufregend mit anderen
worten die quantentheorie würde dann zu
einer quanten informationstheorie
erweitert werden und wir würden das
universum als supercomputer beschreiben
können vorreiter ist hier wieder juanma
zehner der auf der grundlage seiner
theoretischen arbeiten in denen er die
möglichkeit von quantenverschränkung in
wurmlöcher nachwies dass das die
traumzeit durch die teilchen
verschränkung erzeugt werden könnte
das wäre schon ein treppenwitz der
wissenschaftsgeschichte wenn die
relativitätstheorie einsteins auf der
seiner meinung nach kräften
verantwortung
also viel paradoxen teilchen
verschränkung beruhen würde die physiker
glauben dass die teilchen verschränkung
ein grundprinzip ist und nicht nur über
große entfernungen sondern auch am
selben ort existiert und die raumzeit
würde eben durch diese zahlreichen
verschränkungen aufgezogen oder
aufgespannt werden wie ein tuch die
wissenschaftler des computers projektes
wollen deshalb jetzt die gravitation aus
einer quanten perspektive beschreiben
und dabei wollen wir alles ein wenig
vereinfachen um zu einer lösung zu
kommen
sie greifen auf das holografische
prinzip zurück um zu einer lösung zu
gelangen und wollen die berechnungen auf
einer zweidimensionalen hülle anstellen
und damit sind wir wieder bei juan mata
10 er hat bereits bei einem modell
universum dem anti dewitte raum
nachgewiesen dass er sich vollkommen
durch eine sogenannte konforme feld
theorie beschreiben lässt
die allein auf dessen zweidimensionaler
höhle liegt war ja das hört sich wieder
ein bisschen nach unserem holografische
universum an aber es kommt noch besser
und das hat mit der unzuverlässigkeit
von quantencomputern zu tun
die cubis in den quantencomputer werden
durch ein hintergrundrauschen von
teilchen gestört und fallen in einen
eindeutigen zu stellen bevor sie etwas
berechnen konnten sie sind damit für die
berechnung verloren gegangen dann geht
in diese berechnung möglichst wenig
stören oder diese fehler möglichst wenig
stören werden die berechnungen auf
zahlreiche verschränkte cubis verteilt
zum erkennen der fehler wird eine
quanten fehlerkorrektur eingesetzt und
die mathematik die dahinter steckt ist
genau die gleiche wie bei der konformen
feld theorie mit der der anti dritter
raum geschrieben wird hier kann das
innere eines fahrtenbuches durch ein
netzwerk von verschränkung auf dessen
oberfläche beschrieben werden dieses
netzwerk ist auch ein korrektur code mit
der gleichen mathematik wie die
fehlerkorrektur in einem quantencomputer
zitat warum bloß findet man quanten
fehlerkorrekturen bei schwarzen löchern
die erkenntnis kam vollkommen unerwartet
zitat ende das sagt die israelische
sängerin corinna hahn auf eine der
leitenden wissenschaftlerinnen bei den
vom club passen wirklich spannende
zeiten wenn dem weltall parallelen zu
quantencomputern hier auf der erde
finden
vielleicht sind wir dem es schon
wirklich sehr nahe ich hatte euch hier
auf jeden fall auf dem laufenden
das nächste video zum thema konnten
informatik kommt bestimmt damit ihr
nichts verpasst wird mir hier ein abo
aufsaugen vergesst nicht den auf die
glocke hier geht es weise an mit einem
video über den oft erwähnten juan bagger
zehner und seine erkenntnisse zu warm
löchern und der teilchen verschränkung
sehr sehr spannend also bis dann bleibt